twenty years ago Ricky Martin walked out
on the stage with Selya Cruz and Gloria
Estefan at the Latin Grammy Awards and
made history now two decades later he's
back in this time he's hosting you think
back to that moment when you walked out
Gloria Estefan cell your cruise it
changed the way things are so how does
it feel to be back here now
it is very special because it is an
amazing platform for us
Latin musicians to to talk about her
music and and then and then after that I
was able to around the world singing in
Spanish and I went to China I don't want
to Australia and France and and many
countries were or Spanish is not spoken
and and we were we were embraced and and
not only that so back then we were
talking about the Latin explosion right
and and then all of a sudden 20 years
later we're reliving everything with
this wave of young new artists that are
that are unapologetic that are willing
to say things that that need to be
talked about and and to be able to live
it for the first time now to be able to
still be part of it it's it's not
nothing but gratitude for the for for
the crowd thank you
[Music]
you talk about those young artists like
someone like bad bunny for true you are
you're dropping your song today two of
you and it's a song though that harkens
back to the 70s and is an antler in many
senses it was very very beautiful to
receive a phone call from you know the
the gurus of tropical sounds of afonya
and for them to say listen we trust you
we love what you do and we would love
for you to we'll give you the masters
and we want you to play with these
sounds and we live and revive all those
all those rhythms and then you know once
again fusion we have bossa nova we we
have afro Caribbean sounds we have
obviously you know south side and pop
which is which is the main flag at this
point and once again it's all about
fusion is so it's all about letting
people know that when we you know when
we get together with you know people
that are influenced by different
different genres and and we sit down in
a studio and we start exchanging ideas
it's been very refreshing bro it's it's
been very healthy and the reaction of
the crowd if I just go by social media
it's it's it's been insane people are
losing their minds right now yeah I'm
losing my mind
huh and for people who don't know this
really is like an anthem in the Latin
community so people have to understand
yeah I would like I would like to
compare and with all the respect in the
world as it seems like like hade you
well this song which is called Contador
but but originally was called me gente
that's that's it's the same emotion is
it that's what that's what this song
creates in people and and especially for
the Latin community so it doesn't matter
you know how old you are or where you
come from you will feel the same the
same emotions it's it's it's festive is
but at the same time it's about unity is
about it's about telling people go out
there have fun be yourself and
be loud and this is in a sense kind of
an anthem like la vida loca right of
course
my god in the cup of life that's those
were the songs in my career even though
that was not the beginning of my career
but those were the songs that pretty
much you know broke the boundaries and
United cultures and and that's a song
that I will always be singing if I don't
sing livin la vida loca people go what's
wrong with you yeah oh he came for the
yeah and and and it's it's a big
responsibility to be able to once again
play with these sounds and once again
the fact that you know that Fania
allowed me to play with this but those
rhythms it's just nothing but what a
gift what does it mean to be hosting the
Grammys tonight and I know Alicia Keys
is gonna be here he hosted the grand
also and that kind of changed the way we
look at things you know when he had
Alicia he was very funny because since
it's a the anniversary of 20 years of a
Latin Grammy I was like what can I do to
be part of the celebration I didn't
release an album back then so I was not
eligible to be nominated and all of a
sudden I get a phone call from from the
Academy and they say Rick would you
would you
and I'm like of course I've never done
this before I've never hosted an award
ceremony in my life am i anxious about
it I'm in a very beautiful and healthy
way yes I am anxious about it but it's
it's gonna be fun I'm surrounded by two
amazing actresses rustling sanchez paz
vega and a great production who was
really protecting us and once again it's
it's it's very soulful but we're
preparing what you're going to be able
to see that evening it's a very soulful
you did a little acting and that went
really really well so
I mean maybe hosting will do the same
before and after it could just be the
beginning of something I need to be on
stage III need the immediate reaction of
the audience and and and let's see what
hey I don't know man let's see what
happens I hope you enjoy what I do I
think we're ready I hear that you are
gonna come out and set the place on fire
I was in that rehearsal here I'm just
saying who just hearing it was really
good man yeah it was really good it was
really good obviously to be able to be
on the stage with dressing into who has
like 27 Grammys and then obviously that
funny it's it's once again United in
uniting genres uniting different points
of views and and all we want to do is go
on stage and have it and have a good
time and and and feed of what the the
reactions of the audience is gonna be
like it I'm sure it's gonna be very
positive
you say you need that audience you're
going out on tour I am I am are you
excited for that and does everybody go
on tour with you
you know everybody has in my entire
family entire family yeah you're taking
Evers everybody hubby hey come on it is
it is important we starting February 17
Puerto Rico and then we go to Chile
Argentina and then it's gonna be
non-stop I can't wait that's a lot Ricky
moving it's one thing like moving kids
who are a little bigger yeah babies baby
yeah but you know what they chose me as
daddy so they knew what life was gonna
be like before they even they were even
born that's the way I see it I'm a very
spiritual guy and that's the way I see
things in and
did you see beautiful to see you just
clap and she danced oh yes she's 10
months old and she's got three she's
gotta go she's got the rhythm yeah it's
gonna be fine
they're troopers do you sing I do I do
never ever oh my god
we're creating a monster she has it in
her genes it's it's their Super Bowls in
Miami this year any chance they oh
that's crazy yeah it's gonna be very
special uh I will be watching I will be
watching
I mean maybe have fun in Miami you know
from I'll be there I don't know we'll
see what happens but it's it's really
nice when you can you know make such a
powerful event with sports it's a very
beautiful and cultural event as well
yeah and now the fact that they're
opening the doors to to Latin sounds to
be part of the celebration it's
something that I'm having a really
really good time if you're gonna have
Latin sounds are you coming from what do
you know that I don't know is there
something I'm using I don't know let's
see what happens in the meantime I know
Jennifer Lopez insecure will do amazing
more acting in the future I would love
that I would love that I had an amazing
opportunity to work with Ryan Murphy and
obviously Penelope Cruz damn Chris Edgar
Ramirez I got a nomination I got an Emmy
nomination so that's the industry and
the audience saying that I did a good
job all I have to say is that I would
wake up every morning at 5 o'clock in
the morning to read my scripts and study
and and and I always had a good time on
set and and people that I've done this
forever said Ricky we must have done
something really really good
just about the fact that we're having
such a good time doing this and it was a
really dark and intense story I was his
partner
I loved him he was a genius
we the whole cast we would we would
spend our days off together so that says
a lot of how magical it was to be able
to work with Ryan Murphy's production
yeah I mean I mean we soaked it up so I
was like I feel like there's a movie or
something is in your future something
you say it louder I'll say yeah or
something's in your future something
right let's see what happened so love it
um new album tell me what can you tell
me about it so uh hopefully it'll come
out in February and enough look myself
in the studio for the last eight months
and and every time I show something what
I'm working on two people that know
about musicals Rick the good thing about
this is that it doesn't sound like
anything out there that's exactly what
you want to hear and and I'm I haven't
felt like this in a long time with my
music I guess I'm in a really good place
professionally personally my family my
culture I go back to Puerto Rico and and
and I feel that my people need to say a
lot and I'm just grabbing their thoughts
and I'm and I'm just opening that
channel to be able to to send a message
out there of progress of unity and and
it's something that is not only
happening in Puerto Rico the whole
continent needs to hear about this the
US needs to hear about this Europe as
well and and I can we I can't wait to be
back next year with mine I know
Oh any surprises on there anybody
surprising that we wait that we're gonna
be like whoa well you know what it's not
over till it's over
livin la vida loca was born at the end
of the production when we were mixing
that album
all of a sudden livin la vida loca
showed up so the creative process it's
still open and and I'm I'm willing to
exchange ideas with different artists to
want to jump anybody come here yeah
let's make it happen
now in the chew of conker Vegas what
advice would you have for Kelly Clarkson
yes Kelly love oh my god you're gonna
have a great time it's it's uh it's very
beautiful I mean Vegas is it's a city
that it's a magnet for crowds from all
over the world so you will be able to
see different flags from all over the
world enjoying your music Kelly's so
just have a good time for you amazing
you're great you're not gonna have a
phone with this
you're comin coming to see you I will
your show was a lot though you were
runnin around us steroids but that's
that's how I do things
my mom goes you do things big if no you
don't do them right huh mom I'm a
Capricorn I'm stubborn and I and I like
challenges and and I I think Vegas was a
very beautiful challenge that inspired
me to do what I'm doing today Thursday
night before you walk out on the stage
will be the last thing that you think
I'm gonna ask for a little bit of
silence and and do a little bit of
meditation and then and then my family
man my kids they'll be watching at home
my husband as well and it's gonna be
dedicated to them because we've been
away for a whole week it's too much for
me that's a long time so this is gonna
be just it's gonna be all about them in
my heart and soul look for fireworks
when Ricky hits the stage to perform his
new song with bad bunny and resident a
called cantaloupe